la ligne 18 qui devrait relier orly et
versailles chantiers d'ici 2030 ne fait
pas que des heureux
des habitants de voisins-le-bretonneux
sont inquiet du tracé actuel du métro
automatique
elle devrait passer sous leur habitation
dont le sol est déjà fragilisé le tracé
actuel présentation de la difficulté
d'une part il passe sous une zone
résidentielle alors que tout est fait
généralement pour éviter de passer sous
les habitations ce sont des habitations
qui se trouve sur un terrain argileux
parti rend sensible aux phénomènes de
retrait-gonflement des argiles qui
composaient déjà beaucoup de problèmes à
ces habitations donc le tunnel du métro
risquerait de provoquer des difficultés
complémentaires
la société du grand paris a lancé depuis
le 21 mars dernier une enquête publique
sur le sujet 1300 remarques ont déjà été
déposés sur internet
de leur côté ils assurent que la
discussion est ouverte et qu'un tracé
alternatif peut être trouvés en cas de
litige
nos étudiants le les modifications de ce
tracé et les bureaux d'études que nous
employons sont en train de vérifier la
faisabilité de tracé qui ne passeraient
pas sous ce quartier de la bretonnière
donc je crois que il est important que
le cette enquête publique permettent aux
habitants de s'exprimer
l' enquête publique se terminera le 26
avril d'ici là la société du grand paris
organisera une réunion jeudi prochain à
20h au pavillon pierre waldeck rousseau
de guyancourt
l'objectif informer et recueillir les
remarques des habitants de
l'agglomération